[Music]
I know it's terrible honey but thank you
he said it was delicious
Oh Trevor do you want to join us for
Sunday dinner no can do
Trevor your mother invited you to sit
down sit down
hey Jerri well why don't you eat my ass
what is he still doing in the house
I thought he moved into the house with
like 15 of his friends it didn't work
out they turned out all to be
backstabbers and Liars all 15 of them
they were nasty to him boy needs a job
Jerry you got fired from Ashish my dad
got him that job it wasn't his fault
they were nasty to him they wouldn't let
him choose what time he came in so he
just didn't show up what are you saying
honestly he has to sleep in or he'll
lose his voice besides he doesn't have
time for a job he's very busy with ro
shoo
what is ro shoe ro shoe is an ultra
beast Trevor created look at the
beautiful pictures he makes mom don't
put that on the fridge the details are
fantastic Chrissy
now ro shoe is the king of the Bangalow
people and he defeated malgor in the
Battle of lights
he's a lich creased oh is that how you
say a cherry and my rich rich priest I
don't freaking know it's a bunch of
cartoons with their dicks out Jerry
well your arse ooh some artists asked
him to draw a picture of his mother and
me in Wings jerseys it gives me a
freakin drippin hog Chrissy you should
see the details on that hog it's as if
he's seen it down to the veins